la plupart des femmes voilées sont
affiliés à un mouvement marginal ici le
mouvement salafiste une branche
ultra-orthodoxe de l'islam importés dans
les années 90 par des imams ayant
séjourné en arabie saoudite comme
abdelkader bouziane ancien imam de
vénissieux l'une des chevilles ouvrières
de ce mouvement
en 2004 il a été expulsé de france pour
ses positions radicales sur les
relations hommes-femmes la fin à ses
droits la femme aline voleur mais dans
des casses trop serré qu'on peut frapper
la femme exemple la femme 30 ce matin là
si c'était vrai il peut la frappe et ne
pas viser le visage ne pas viser les
yeux les oreilles le nez non frappé en
bas c'est à dire les fesses alors nous
avons voulu savoir qui se cache sous ces
voiles qui sont ces jeunes femmes
séduites par un discours rigoriste
en tout cas elles n'ont pas leur langue
dans leur poche quand il s'agit de
défendre leurs tenues interdire
quelqu'un de s'habiller comme elle veut
interdire quelqu'un de rester chaste et
de se préserver
c'est aussi barbare que ce que disent
les gens qui disent que nous on nous
oblige et qu'une autre voile fait du mal
alors qu'il fait du mal à personne
comme chaque semaine des jeunes gens
viennent ici se convertir une vingtaine
par mois en moyenne
c'est le cas de cette jeune femme en
voile gris cette française de 24 ans
s'appelle christelle pour quelques
minutes encore
puis elle se fera appeler chahinez rien
dans l'islam n'oblige christelle à venir
à la mosquée couvertes de la tête aux
pieds
d'ailleurs que dit au juste le coran sur
la tenue vestimentaire des femmes
voici ce qui est écrit dit aux croyantes
de démontrer que l'extérieur de leurs
atours et qu'elles rabattent leur voile
sur leurs poitrines tout est affaire
d'interprétation porter une tenue
décente pour les uns un foulard sur les
cheveux pour les autres
celles qui choisissent de se couvrir
entièrement ne dise pas que c'est le
coran qui les y oblige mais qu'elles
veulent suivre l'exemple des femmes du
prophète
à l'époque les épouses de mohamed
étaient les seuls à s'habiller ainsi en
signe de respectabilité
alors pourquoi de nouvelles musulmane
vont elles si loin dans leur pratique de
l'islam
samir amghar et sociologues
il s'est immergé plusieurs mois dans les
milieux salafistes pour préparer sa
thèse il a interviewé des dizaines de
femmes converties pour comprendre leurs
motivations à porter le voile intégral
à partir du moment où on est convertie à
l'islam
on a quelque part un déficit de
légitimité parce qu'on n'est pas issu
d'une famille musulmane dont quelque
part le fait de devenir c'est la fille
permet à l'individu qui se convertit de
rattraper le temps perdu et des quelque
part plus musulman que le musulman
d'origine
on a une respectabilité on devient
notamment cartier